attention attention on passe au blind
test
alors le blind tc st patrick braouzec je
vous le dis il faut me donner le nom de
l'interprète et non pas le titre de la
chanson d'accord alors on va faire un
petit exemple didier si tu veux bien
c'est bien voilà c'était dur c'était
très dur non alors en pleine c'est la
chanson s'appelle pomme et c'est parce
que le blind test est consacré ce soir
aux fruits vous avez vous aidé à
chercher seulement 1 s'est consacré aux
fruits et pour arbitrer le blind test
j'appelle manche sur lui pour porter
à
l'équipe et les amis copains
safadi le plus important si vous perdez
vous êtes obligé de mettre mon costume
de bananes peu banal à côtes d'annaba et
donc chef déco ça sera le jeu du homard
donc pas sûr que non jamais qu'est ce
qu'ils gagnent les gens alors les autres
médias nadia rares des poires pour eux
oui des pommes paris des membres des
poires et des scoubidous belfort corti
donc très fort dans les enchaînements
corti didier premières chansons
ghani va gagner 3 pas sûr qu'ils gagnent
non c'est pas sûr qu'ils gagnent
pourquoi en quoi moi jean-françois enfin
vous avez fait tellement émission sur la
chanson et le championnat mais il est
trop rapide
non c'est pas ça c'est qu'ils répondent
avant qu'on a entendues par le principe
c'est de reconnaître aux premiers
accords l'ailé
bah oui c'est arrivé une fois ce n'est
pas à chaque fois je t'ai format ça oui
révélation quand la fontaine
une équipe
aujourd'hui on va laisser une l'homme
contre les jaguars bien d'accord la
somme journée et à boby lapointe bravo
boby lapointe grange émission [ __ ]
c'est assez c'est un génie qui est mort
il est mort
ruiné avant dans un sous virait sa
maison dit alors c'est bien on dit que
s'agit ni après oui là j'aurais préféré
qu'on dit saint génies vivants
il a cassé l'ambiance canon troisième
chanson
il adorait
oui
reconnu dans la noble et c'est serge
replay sinon celle de sailly
jean-françois 4 on n'est pas sûr de
savoir qui a répondu c'est comme au
stade de france et 6 1 contre vidéo
ripper peut primer les messieurs
la marque est à mon goût c'est normal en
montant alors égalité 2-2 chanson numéro
5 du tier 1
m
pour parler plus fort et là vous risquez
d'handicapés votre équipe à lisa je vous
le dis mais c'est effectivement serge et
charlotte gainsbourg dans lemon incest
puisqu'on voulait remarqué il ya que des
fruits dans ce blind test chanson numéro
6 ce qu'on semble traîner
jean françois kahn
le noir est ce que 2
donc l'équipe des pommes ita kat et
l'équipe des poires et à 2 7 me lié à la
mort
non c'est bien madame aux aînés
canadiens charles maroilles il a mené à
des road ils ont joué la marseillaise je
pouvais politique pour la politique
c'est vrai que c'est un des meilleurs
politique ça fait du bien au pcf voyez
mais oui le tandem d'ailleurs politique
qu'il s'est trop vieux ce que vous
passez il faudrait prendre des trucs
plus m'arrêter moi le mariage a eu tout
à l'air d'aller voir y'a des trucs plus
tard sans en revanche c'est très très
dur
les halles ont perdu plus d'un anr total
istèque attention note didier à berne où
un incroyable adamo comme c'est son
affaire d'amour et six essais qui de la
musique je sais de cette chanson je ne
sais pas c'est un classique verdi n'ont
pas voilà je pensais que je vous le dis
qu'on s'est fait vers 10 6 georgette
plana cavell en championnat au départ et
c'est vers 10 est tiré d'un opéra de
verdi rigoletto vous êtes mis des poires
oui c'est vrai mais elle a fait sa job
dans le film de richard berry que ça
vous va très bien alain sais j'ai du mal
à bolton sam etiassé 7,2 juste je
voudrais juste rappeler car cela veut
dire qu'à d'amour
owen
il
m
fabre kecil de france a trouvé ses prix
une serre à ce périmètre est
effectivement chanson à la reprise j'ai
revu quelques trucs vieux bancs cemetery
c'est bien là le truc en vain - l'a300
trois là là oui c'est vrai d'amuser a
marqué la rupture des générations quand
même bien qu'adam vous avez trois temps
non non non non à mulhouse
croyez moi j'ai trois firmes tout à
l'heure tout à l'heure aux accords entre
belges prévoient bonnichon via un prêt
dur qu'à me trouver
qui
le score est de 8 à 3 il n'y aura pas de
super banco il n'y aura pas de jeu du
homard et non et non donc nous allons
tuer le homard non non non non le tuba
nomade c'est mon home a bien bravo à
m'isoler tel qu'il va montrer alors
cessé d'y aller dans l'été lui je suis
effectivement
merci à tous c'était tout le monde en
parle
laurent mbassi sexe magouille et culture
générale de laurent baffie
avec l'embellie pascal sellem mano morin
gagne à l'oustau et géraldine bonnet
guérin au théâtre du gymnase gérard
jugnot à la fiche du film in lavandier
ou mais le 18 avril avec emilie dequenne
sortie de la vidéo et du délai des
meilleurs espoirs féminin de gérard
jugnot avec jérôme
je elisa tovati à la fille de laurence
nous la vérité si je mens 2 avec des
gens de minarets josé garcia
mais mon solo gilbert memphis cadel
manet et gagner le prévôt marcel
desailly merci joueur à chelsea et
capitaine de l'équipe de france de
football merci d'être venus salvatore
adamo sortie de l'album par les temps
qui courent et le single en promo le
futur n'existe pas adamo actuellement en
tournée jean françois kahn sortie du
livre les rebelles celles et ceux qui
ont dit non chez plon sortie du livre
moi l'autre et le loup c'est ty ar
cécile de france à la fiche du film
richard berry l'art délicat de la
séduction avec richard berry la victime
gît d'al-hassaba jean pierre darroussin
et ludmila mikaël à la digue
baby voilà merci à patrick braouzec et
bravo à nicolas escudé pour la
demi-finale de la coupe davis qui nous
qualifie en septembre pour les demi
finale contre les pays bas voilà
effectivement lampard rémission pas
comme les autres
rendez-vous dans huit jours c'est le
soir